boo it's Halloween guys according to a
handful of polls belief in ghosts may be
on the rise a 2007 ap Ipsos poll found
that 1/3 of American adults believed in
ghosts in a 2011 CBS News question 40
percent said that they believed that
ghosts or the spirits of the Dead could
come back now it's half additionally an
October 2017 Chapman University poll
found that 52 percent believe in
hauntings and believe in the paranormal
might even be more common than that the
Chapman University survey says that
nearly 75% of us believe in at least one
of seven paranormal phenomenon like
extraterrestrials clairvoyance or
Bigfoot and yet Americans don't think
they're very superstitious in an AP poll
79% of Republicans and Democrats that
they weren't superstitious so how can
Americans be skeptical and superstitious
at the same time maybe it's only a
superstition when other people believe
it is one Bigfoot hunter said just
because I hunt Bigfoot doesn't mean I
believe everything I hear it appears
that belief in ghosts is increasing what
do you think let us know your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI